[Musique]
monsieur benalla prétend que c'est
passeport était resté à l'elysée et qui
lui aurait été remis par un agent de
l'elysée j'ai bien entendu ce qu'a dit
monsieur benalla et je dis haut et fort
ici que premièrement les mesures qui ont
été prises et que je viens de vous
détailler et pour lesquels il existe des
notes de service des courriers qui sont
à votre disposition permettent
d'affirmer que les passeports n'étaient
pas à l'elysée je vous réaffirme
solennellement sous serment encore une
fois que le 19 septembre mais passeport
était à l'elysée patrick strzoda vous a
affirmé que ces passeports avaient été
utilisées entre le 1er et le 7 août
ce que je ne dénie pas c'est la réalité
je les ai restituer à la demande de la
présidence de la république et du
ministère des affaires étrangères qui
m'a adressé deux courriers ainsi qu'un
email que j'ai reçu de la part du
général bio-farina le 30 juillet j'ai
restituer mais passeport les clés de mon
bureau
le badge d'accès à l'elysée et j'ai
récupéré un certain nombre d'autres
affaires comme un siège auto et un
chéquier une perte de clés également
il a fait une troisième demande très
précisément le 23 mai 2018
cette demande il adressé directement je
dis bien directement sans passer par le
service du protocole et a fortiori un
échelon hiérarchique supérieur il
adressé directement aux services du quai
d'orsay
vous même vous avez fait votre demande
directement au quai d'orsay c'est pas
exactement comme ça que ça s'est passé
comment ça cela s'est il passé je le
dirai la juge d'instruction mais
peut-être qu'elle ne vous le demandera
pas tandis que moi je vous le demande
tout à fait la question m'a déjà été
posée en garde à vue moi en tout cas je
peux vous affirmer que j'ai informé des
personnes qui devaient en connaître par
courtoisie encore une fois la présidence
je les fais en mon nom propre en ma
responsabilité concernant les autres
acteurs se soient des ministres ou des
responsables d'administrations je ne
sais pas quels ont été leurs démarches
ou pas nous avons été informés les
déplacements de monsieur linh à la part
des interrogations de la presse
aux environs de du 20 décembre du 20
décembre 2018
quelques jours avant que le président de
la république se rende au tchad
nous avons été interrogés plusieurs
questions est ce que vous allez
connaissance que monsieur pénale à
sevran dans les plusieurs pays africains
et qu'il utiliserait son passeport
diplomatique c'est comme ça que nous
l'avons su pas d'autre moyen de le
savoir